patrick corbin bringing that arsenal of
his yeah we'll look for our veteran
starter to throw strikes early similar
to john lester last night
but he's just a little longer and
lankier guy
that ball is drilled to left field it's
a fair ball going to the corner
and mccutchen's on his way to second
with his third double of the year
and right out of the gate he's in
scoring position without bryce harper
bouncer toward the middle trey turner
has it on the slide
it's going to be an infield hit for
bryce harper now it's first and third so
that'll bring up reese hoskin
swing and a miss corbin takes him
upstairs
with a 93 hitter for a big second out
bring up alec balm and a throw over the
first they got harper picked off
mccutcheon breaks for the plate the
throw and he
is safe at home played mccutcheon gets
underneath the tag of yon gomes
and the phillies pull off the double
steal they lead it one to nothing
john gomez had to jump for it and andrew
look
that is a great slide now
harper takes off for third but balm is
swing
and a foul tip held by gomes he strikes
out
the inning ends zach keflin last time
out against atlanta in atlanta six and
two thirds five hits two runs eight
strikeouts
josh harrison oh for four tuesday night
well placed take your time josh
he can round the bag and check in with a
knock nice he earned that
nick one soto had a swing and a hot shot
diving stop natan's got it from his
knees throws to second
and they'll get the out there what a
play by nick maton
diving up the middle and getting a throw
off to segura for the second out so
here's kyle schwarber
two career hits two rbis against eflin
and that makes a loud sound to deep left
field
see you later
kyle schwab oppo for a homer first time
as
annette and it's a two-to-one game
schwab just heating up
he's been right on the nose the whole
series castro
draws a two-out walk after the home run
the inning continues
and josh bell will come up and he goes
yard
see you later
a tremendous home run into the second
deck in
section 240. bang zoom goes bell
with his fourth home run of the year a
tape measure
shot single and a blast a walk
and a blast and then ants have a
four-run first inning
so we go top of the second patrick
corbin suddenly has a three-run lead
with which to work and he gets herrera
swing and a miss on a great corbin slide
he is fanned three in a row swinging
brings up maton hitting 297.
he pulls it into right field at base
head
ninth hit against the left-hander for
maton he's now nine
for 21. zac eflin will come to the plate
and a swing of the tap her back to the
mound corbin has it'll jog toward first
underhanded toward bell and then fear
doors right toward the dugout as the
inning is over
we'll go to the bottom of the second
patrick corbin leads off
and a call strike three that ball comes
back that's the pitch he was looking for
in the first inning and it just wasn't
coming all the way back
here goes robles there you go strike
three call
back to back strikeouts perfect pitch by
upland
see where andrew's setting up away trey
turner will be the batter
and a called strike three comes back he
strikes out the side all three
strikeouts looking
and we'll head to the third inning
corbin has two quick ground ball outs
here in the third
here's bryce harper who reached on the
infield head
right down the middle maybe outer half
and harper with a bad toss and a helmet
drop
a lot of calm third strikes around this
place lately last to the third
josh harrison will lead off swinging a
miss
four straight strikeouts
for zach and it brings in juan soto
three balls and two strikes
swinging a miss he won the battle got it
with a slider that's five
strikeouts in a row for zach eflett here
comes kyle schwarber
and a gold strike three six strikeouts
of the row
schwarber slams his helmet there's the
fine
seven in a row retired by eflin
including six strikeouts we go to the
fourth
two away in the top of the fourth here's
odubal herrera
shoots it the other way that'll be a
base hit for herrera schwarber
cuts it off herrera holds up at first
two out single
that snaps the streak of six in a row
retired for corbin and then it brings up
the catcher andrew knapp then a swing
and a miss to strike him out
on a slider in the dirt golem supplies
the tag so corbin gets strikeout number
five
the phillies strand the two out single
and we go to the bottom of the fourth
zac effluent
struck out the last six hitters that's a
new career high for him but starlin
castro will lead off the inning
and a line drive past the diving third
baseman balm and a base hit into left
field
starlin castro an 11 game hitting streak
and then breaks the run of six
consecutive strikeouts for effluent
josh bell homer on the first pitch is
first time up
ground ball right side should be two
there's one natan throws low dugout by
hoskins
four six three double play two outs here
in the fourth
dion gomes the hitter swing and a miss
seven strikeouts for effluent side is
retired here in the fourth
we'll go to the fifth after corbin takes
a 4-1 lead to the hill for the fifth
nick maton the shortstop will lead it
off for the phillies
nick maton boy this kid's a tough out
now we've got starbucks played by castro
fully stretched down
so was josh bell on the other end well
that's
that's what happens when you have short
stops all over the field as we do
so top of the order now and andrew
mccutchen who double the left
as mccutchen swings and grounds one left
side turner up with it
throw across to bell and it's a very
quick one two three inning for patrick
corbin go to the sixth it's four to one
nationals
so the big bats here in this inning
facing corbin for a third time segura
harper and hoskins
one hopper josh bell ground ball out
number nine
for patrick corbin bryce harper will
make his way to the plate
gonna miss 82 on that one
strikeout number seven for patrick
corbin
rhys hoskins strikeout and the grounder
to short check swing ball in the dirt
and strike three says the home plate
umpire jeff nelson goldman supplies the
tag
and the inning is over bottom of the
sixth inning here's juan soto
that's a base hit
if you throw your glove at the ball
isn't that like two extra bases for the
hitter
yeah it is soto at second now after the
broken bat hit the nationals trying to
add to a 4-1 lead with
the hot-hitting starling castro that's
fair
and it's under the glove of bone around
the score of soda
schwarber to third bob henley's gonna
hold him
and the nationals lead 5-1 as stalin
castro the hit machine sneaks one down
the third base line
patrick knew they were going to walk you
on so he's down to first base base is
loaded
maybe patrick corbin's the guy who
breaks the game open
there's nine strikeouts for zach
effluent today the new
season high but the nationals had a run
we're going to the seventh
it's five to one as corbin will start
the inning balm shoots a line driving to
left for a base hit
got a slider up in the zone and for the
phillies their first lead off base
runner since the first inning
and o'double herrera to the plate that's
a beauty
absolute beauty strikeout number nine
for patrick corbin
corbin out away from finishing seven
innings
fly ball left center schwarber and
robles communicate gentlemen
kyle calls it that's it patrick corbin
if that's it for him today it's by far
his best start of the year but this is
getting harry with runners on first and
second one out and he's going to face
bryce harper three balls two strikes to
harper one out
and a miss on 98.
for the biggest down of the game with
two down here in the eighth
now hoskins the batter right at kester
he'll go the long way to first
stretch by bell he stayed on the back
and then answer out of the
gutsy stuff from daniel hudson we go to
the ninth inning here at nationals park
and austin both
is on the pitch swing and a miss
95 appeared to have some away action
on boom there so two out here in the top
of the ninth inning the nationals and
out away and andrew knapp will be the
hitter
swinging a ground ball toward the middle
turner playing behind the bag has it
the throw to bell at first and a curly w
is in the books the final score the
washington nationals five
the philadelphia phillies won